[Applause]
I'm so happy to meet you I am so
I'm thrilled to meet you I really am
this is
um it's very personal for me in a world
where we're all trying to figure out who
we're supposed to be the risk yes
bravery oh my gosh I had no idea how
vulnerable I was even willing to get and
honestly that day one video that I made
it was kind of supposed to be a comedy
video because I think coming outs can be
so intense and you know I kind of wanted
to add some some humor I think that we
can all learn through comedy I think you
can relate it's my lifeline now I I do
think that there was so much that came
up this year that I had no idea that I
was going to have to figure out in
Womanhood and and vulnerable things that
I didn't even know were there well let
me ask you is it true that Laverne Cox
you met her but what she said to you
wasn't what I thought she was going to
say say to you what was it she said to
keep some things private for myself and
I couldn't agree more in the way that
there were a few moments this year where
I was like was I actually ready to say
that but now since meeting her and
having that moment I go okay what would
Laverne do and I actually have stopped
myself from making a few videos to make
sure that I was actually ready to talk
about those things and how does it feel
you know has that wisdom guided you in
ways that you're glad you heard it or
you're still figuring that out still
figuring it out but I think back to my
like childhood self and I think about if
I was following myself on Tick Tock as
like a young kid what would I want to
hear or you know so much of my audience
is a younger demographic and I sort of
would love to show transness in a way
that we haven't seen it before because I
figured when I came out that I might
have to go into hiding and then do all
my surgeries privately and change my
name and I instead decided hey let me
see if the world is willing to accept me
this way from day one and they did and
you actually have some really supportive
interesting followers I'm just going to
kick it off with Lady Gaga oh my gosh I
love her I mean I had the Born This Way
ball like poster on my my wall and now
you know she every video there's like a
little something from her and I can't
wait to meet her that's the best part I
will say there's so much hatred and
drama and you know just things get
convoluted but getting to meet you know
my role models even you today is like
it's the best part not gonna lie let me
ask you about the negativity how have
you dealt with it and and what's an
approach you take what's your self-talk
what do you filter yes how do you I
still read the comments but there is so
much hatred directed to the trans
Community right now it's everywhere and
I think the greatest weapon that I can
control tribute is trans joy in comedy
and talking about hard you know subjects
and really intricate moments of a
transition and try to let everybody in
to see that you know I'm not a monster
I'm not somebody that you know is trying
to to do anything but be myself and be
happy
love you thank you everybody for that
support how do you stay on your own path
where do you draw boundaries where do
you find the strength to keep being the
joy well I think having my chosen family
and the people that I love to take care
of me but I also think there's something
just about uh making sure that you're
you don't put something out there before
you're ready and and really just
surrounding yourself with good people
it's interesting because I look at
someone like you and I can't imagine
anybody disliking you oh please do you
know do you want to know ironically who
uh dislikes me the most sometimes myself
oh me too oh and but
[Applause]
you've asked me like what I would do to
combat the hate right yeah but what do
you do okay that's a great question now
you've been doing it little longer than
I have well you know it's funny because
when I was a kid
um you starting with E.T it was the
first time I was introduced to film
reviews which are basically social media
yes but I felt like all these reviews
and it would could be a Charlie's Angels
it could be an E.T it could be the
Wedding Singer everything in between if
you read reviews just like on social
media you are pretty much guaranteed a
50 50
Some Like It some don't so you've got to
be willing to Bear Down Embrace for it
and I think I think picking your battles
too yes and sometimes I think the
greatest uh response can just be in the
next joyous video or in the next win
that you have because that just goes to
show that like you are continuing on and
whatever that those people are
projecting on to you it isn't actually
penetrating I couldn't agree more
because another thing that you're making
me realize is to not carry on in spite
of others I'm sorry I just realized that
I'm sitting on the floor with Drew I'm
so happy to be doing this thank you for
joining me on the floor the floor always
feels safer get this nice all right we
have to go to a quick commercial break I
don't want to but the good news is we'll
be right back
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]